bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous de
débats de chroniqu et de reportages
comme tous les soirs sur Public Sénat
vous connaissez la promesse de
l'émission donner du sens à l'actualité
se mettre au service du public vous
proposz des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société et voici le
sommaire de ce 26 octobre des travaux
d'intérêt général des parents
responsables financièrement des dommages
causé par leurs enfants des peines de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux un
encadrement par des militaires pour les
jeunes délinquants et puis également
davantage de pouvoir aux policiers
municipaux ou encore la création d'une
force d'action républicaine ce sont les
principales mesures annoncées par
isisabel Bor 4 mois après les émeutes on
les décortique avec nos experts dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
gros plan sur Nicolas Sarkozi
officiellement retiré de la vie
politique depuis ce jour de novembre
2016 où il perd les primaires de la
droite et du centre
il est donc temps maintenant pour
moi d'orter une
vie avec plus de passion
privé et moins de passion publique 7 ans
plus tard c'est un exprésident qui
navigue entre influence politique affair
judiciaire et business lucratif de
conseil auprès des entreprises il fait
l'objet d'un livre enquête intitulé Le
Parin l'expression justifié ou
caricaturale ne ratez pas la
confrontation de nos invités dans trois
quart d'heure mais d'abord avant les
annonces de soutien au quartier et aux
jeunes en difficulté prévu demain
c'était le volet sécuritaire de la
réponse aux émeutes de juillet que
présentait la première ministre Flora
sauvage 4 mois après les émeutes qui ont
suivi la mort de naë 17 ans sous les tir
des policiers Élisabeth borne affiche sa
fermeté l'objectif du gouvernement réuni
à la Sorbonne ce jeudi est de renforcer
l'arsenal ré tout en créant un fond de
100 million d'euros pour aider à la
reconstruction des bâtiments endommagés
lors de ces émeutes nous avons constaté
qu'une grande partie des auteurs mineurs
n'avait jamais eu affaire à la justice
il faut donc que nous élargission notre
palette de sanction afin qu'aucun acte
ne reste impuni côté sécurité l'exécutif
veut offrir au police municipale la
possibilité de réaliser certains actes
de police judiciaire une mesure déjà
présente dans le projet de loi de
sécurité globale mais qui avait été
retoqué par le Conseil constitutionnel
le gouvernement crée aussi une force
d'action républicaine une brigade
composée de magistrats de policiers et
de médiateurs afin d'apporter des
réponses spécifiques à un quartier en
cas d'émeut dans son plan l'exécutif
s'attache aux jeunes auteurs
d'infraction tout en visant leurs
parents en leur imposant des travaux
d'intérêt général ou des stages de
responsabilité parentale nous devons
aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin j'y
reviens viendrait mais nous devons aussi
agir face à la démission de certains
devant les dérives de leurs enfants du
côté des sanction pénale l'amende pour
violation du couvrefeu devrait passer de
150 à 750 €. le gouvernement veut aussi
créer une peine de bannissement des
réseaux sociaux lorsque l'infraction a
été commise via une plateforme en ligne
autant de mesures qui visent à éviter un
nouvel embrasement Elizabeth born doit
faire des annonces supplémentaires
vendredi à Chantelou Lévine lors du
comité interministérial des villes pour
combattre les inégalités à la racine
voilà ce volet sécuritaire de la réponse
gouvernementale aux émeut on en débat
tout de suite avec Jean-Philippe dugouin
Clément bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir vous
êtes maire de My en Nesson
vice-président UD de la région
île-de-fance premier vice-président de
l'Association des Maires d'île-de-fance
et puis auteur de ce livre l'habitat
fait le citoyen aux éditions de l'au
laurenceerveau bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes la directrice du cercle de
réflexion destin commun et vous avez
réalisé avec quantard toute une enquête
sur la perception des Français de ces
violences urbaines du mois de juillet
Antoine jardin bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques ingénieur de recherche CNRS
au Centre de recherche sociologique sur
le droit et les institutions pénales
spécialiste des attitudes et
comportements politiques dans les
banlieux des métropoles européennes
j'accueille également Tam tranui bonsoir
Tam bienvenue dans le costume
d'éditorialiste politique ce soir
bienvenue à vous je commence avec un un
sondage qui a été publié ce matin par
confrère du Figaro ça montre quoi ça
montre d'abord une attente des Français
avant on est bien d'accord les premières
mesures annoncées par par ellisabeth
bornne la question depuis les émeutes
diriez-vous que le gouvernement a
suffisamment agi pour éviter qu'elle ne
se reproduise le constat est assez dur
73 % de non Jean encore une fois c'était
avant les annonces hein ça ça aura
peut-être changé demain jean-philiipe
dugouin Clément euh peut-être une une
vision un peu générale qu'est-ce que
vous pensez des des mesures annoncées
cet après-midi ce volet sécuritaire
est-ce que c'est à la hauteur de vos
attente d'élus local si vous voulez déjà
c'est 4 mois après donc c'est beaucoup
de temps qui se sont écoulés et beaucoup
de temps pour des annonces qui pour
l'instant sont assez limités alors vous
l'avez dit on est uniquement sur un
volet sécuritaire beaucoup d'acteurs
attendaient depuis déjà quelques
semaines un plan beaucoup plus large
avec un volet sécuritaire qui est
nécessaire mais aussi un volet
d'accompagnement de développement de ces
quartiers-l et devrait être annoncé
demain normalement on verra ce qu'il y a
demain sur le volet avec le comité
interministériel de la ville normalement
mais on verra ce qui sera annoncé ou
HCR il y a beaucoup beaucoup d' d'Annon
qui est souvent le cas dans ce type de
situation on renvoie beaucoup de choses
à des votes de loi ultérieur qu'on parle
de loi justice de loi sécurité vous
prenez l'exemple des polices municipales
de dire on va augmenter les moy rien ne
dit en quoi on va augmenter les moyens
des polices municipales et d'une
certaine et qui payera c'est les maires
c'est les communes mais d'ailleurs on à
peu près sur l'un des seuls points qui
concerne directement les communes parce
que l'autre truc l'autre chose un petit
peu surprenante c'est de faire une
annonce devant m il y a quasiment aucune
annonce qui concerne directement les
communes au titre de leurs compétences
on aura probablement plus demain si on
parle des mesures de développement
d'acompagnement de moyens dont disposent
les acteurs locaux pour travailler quand
on parle de la politique pénale quand on
parle de créer des épides quand on parle
de centre éducatif fermés quand on parle
de majoration d'amende quand on parle de
tige pour les parents les les les
communes ne sont pas directement en
charge ou concerné donc en fait tout ça
ça fait une impression assez bizarre je
crois qu'il y avait une attente très
forte de beaucoup de Français d'avoir
une réponse sécuritaire pas uniquement
et le gouvernement a choisi cet axe là
ce soir ouais c'était le premier axe
effectivement Laurence de nerveau est-ce
de fait la première demande réclamée par
les Français la réponse sécuritaire
quand on les interroge après ces émeutes
alors nous avions mené effectivement une
enquête juste après les émeutes dans les
tout premiers jours de juillet dernier
et nous avions posé la question aux
Français finalement quelles sont pour
vous les priorités après cet épisode de
la mort de l'année des émeutes qui ont
suivi la réponse qui recueillait le plus
de de de d'adhésion des français c'était
juger et sanctionner ceux qui ont commis
des actes de délinquence c'était 76 % et
donc cette cette priorité était assez
nette chez les Français la réponse qui
est arrivait juste après c'était aider
les commerçants suite au pillage et aux
destruction donc là effectivement le
fond de 100 millions d'euros vient vient
répondre à cette préoccupation mais plus
largement les préoccupations des
Français si vous me permettez d' d'en
dire quelques mots pour donner du sens à
l'actualité comme vous le proposez dans
cette émission je pense qu'il faut se
remettre aussi dans l'état d'esprit qui
était celui des Français à ce moment-là
et 4 mois plus tard c'est difficile pour
nous de revoir ces images qui sont
choquantes hein qui sont très très
marquantes euh et bien ce qui était
frappant dans ce sondage que nous avions
mené c'est que dans un moment de
traumatisme national dans cet épisode
malgré tout et à contrario de ce que le
débat public faisait principalement
ressortir les Français étaient modérés
nuancés demander de l'apaisement et de
la modération moins polarisé qu'on
pouvait l'imaginer mais ça on y
reviendra un peu en détail plus tard
mais c'était effectivement intéressant
de le poser dès le début de de ce de ce
débat Antoine jardin on est dans une
réponse sécuritaire historiquement c'est
on peut dire que c'est classique quand
il y a des violences urbaines il y a
d'abord une réponse sécuritaire ce qu'on
peut trouver d'ailleurs assez logique ça
fait partie finalement de l'alternance
de l'attitude de l'État français par
rapport au quartier populaire depuis une
quarantaine d'années ça fait une
quarantaine d'années qu'il y a des
émeute et il y a toujours eu un volet
sécuritaire et on s'est très vite rendu
compte plusieurs reprises qu'il
suffisait pas d'avoir un volet
sécuritaire et qu'il fallait aussi faire
autre chose donc la décision d'avoir
deux journées d'annonce finalement avec
deux parties du programme ça renvoie à
cette dualité d'action au fait qu'il y a
un besoin de capacité de contrôle social
et en même temps on se rend compte que
ça ne peut pas tenir que par la
répression la justice et la police mais
est-ce que tout n'est pas lié finalement
et bien tout est lié dans le sens où il
y a une cause au comportement de
déviance depposition de confrontation et
cette dimension et c'est une dimension
qui est aussi intrinsèquement politique
on voit bien la question du rapport à la
police dans ces émeutes on voit bien la
question de la contestation de l'action
de la parole du gouvernement euh et donc
ces dimensions politiques elles sont pas
prises en charge par des approch le
seront peut-être demain un peu plus mais
ce sera des approches qui seront
essentiellement économiques et sociales
vraisemblablement mais la question
politique de qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
canal d'expression d'un désaccord
d'expression d'une confrontation qui ne
passe pas par la violence ça c'est une
question qui reste assez largement
ouverte et la question en fait des
moyens de faire émerger des questions
politiques depuis les banlieu sans que
ce soit dans l'affrontement c'est
quelque chose qui reste encore assez
largement à construire euh votre avis
là-dessus je du goin Clément parce que
juste après les émeutes vous aviez
pointé le le manque de reconnaissance
des policiers notamment disant que
finalement on avait eu je met des
guillemet mais peu de jours d'émeutes en
tout cas en comparaison avec d'autres
épisodes et et et c'était d'abord grâce
au policiers vous remettiez ça ça en
avant en disant pas assez de moyens bah
c'est dire que par rapport à 2004 on a
une période d'émeut beaucoup plus courte
beaucoup moins localisée également parce
que la réalité de 2004 j'ai connu les
deux travaillant dans des communes
touchées et 2004 4 ça concernait
essentiellement des villes qpv quartier
politique de la ville avec de la
politique de la ville et des situations
sociales très difficiles là la réalité
c'est qu'on a eu des communes plus
résidentielles des communes rurbaines
des communes rurales qui ont été
touchées de manière moindre que des
communes
sociologiquement plus difficile plus
appauvri mais on l'a retrouvé un petit
peu partout et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
un travail absolument exceptionnel des
forces de l'ordre moi j'ai passé 3
semaines en tant que maire quasiment
jusqu'à 4 5h du matin tous les soirs
dehors dans ma commune et il y a eu un
travail assez exceptionnel il y a pas eu
de victime pendant cette période
d'émeute ce qui est quelque chose quand
on ramène la violence des affrontements
qui ont pu avoir lieu les prises à parti
des attaques de poste de police au
mortiers mais de de manière extrêmement
structurée importante il y a eu un
travail énorme qui a été fait des forces
de l'ordre et je crois qu'il y a eu ce
besoin de reconnaissance mais quand on
enlève la question moyen des forces de
l'ordre vraiment la question sur les
quartiers comment est-ce que on crée une
politique de la ville une politique de
la ville ça ne peut pas être que du tout
répressif et ça ne peut pas non plus
être des mesures où on va aller acheter
une paix sociale et le problème de fond
ça existe trop souvence ben le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on on est entre les
deux euh moi je crois qu'on a besoin de
réinventer aujourd'hui une politique de
la ville vous savez en 2017 le président
Macron avait commandé à Jean-Louis
borlot un rapport ça avait été l'appel
de Grig à l'époque déjà autour de
beaucoup de M ça a été à l'époque 19
propositions qui étaient des axes de
travail qui avaient été lancé concernant
un peu tous les domaine permettant à une
jeunesse à des habitants de quartier de
pouvoir vivre un développement dans leur
territoire et en fait la réalité c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui a été jeté
aux oubliettes à peine il avait été
amené on a reparlé de ça il y a 2 ans
suite aux incidents qu'il avait eu à
Marseille on en reparle aujourd'hui
maintenant et en fait ce que j'espère
c'est qu'on ne sera pas sur un
N une nm
politique communicationnel d'affichage
d'apaisement mais qu'on ira bien sur le
fond pour répondre au problèmes est-ce
que dans les sujets de fond il y a aussi
le fait que on a beaucoup vu les
hmetiers qui se sont attaqués à des
symboles de la République on a vu des
écoles des équipements municipaux on a
vu en plus des postes de police mais
voilà des choses qui sont pas forcément
très classiques qu'est-ce que ça a dit
est-ce que c'est là aussi qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une une réponse pour que
bien cette jeunesse réadhère à la
République Antoine jardin oui ça revvoit
la dimension en fait directement
politique de ces émeutes qui est de dire
on est capable de créer une situation de
désordre que l'État ne saura pas gérer
où aura trop de mal géré pendant
plusieurs jours donc on est mais est-ce
qu'on donne pas pardon vous interrompe
est-ce qu'on donne pas une dimension
politique à des actes qui n'en avaient
pas forcément on fera le portrait des
émotier tout à l'heure il y avait une
session ici au Sénat hier il pas sûr que
tous avaient une volonté politique en
avant mettre le feu à un bureau de poste
quoi vous voyez ce que jeux dire tous
non et on voit bien qu'il a les actes
qui sont de nature différentes aller
voler des baskets dans un magasin qui a
été cassé c'est pas la même chose que
d'aller attaquer une mairie ou d'aller
attaquer un commissariat donc il y a pas
la même dimension de structuration
derrière et on prend le terme d'émeut
pour en fait agglomérer des
comportements de desordres qui ont eu
lieu en même temps mais qui sont pas
tous de même nature et d'ailleurs qui
sont pas de même nature selon les
terrains on va casser des viseries dans
centrre-ville on s'affronte avec les
policiers dans les rues des quartiers
populaires principalement donc il y a eu
vraiment des différences et l'émeut
n'est pas tissé partout de la même
étoffe et je crois qu'il y a une
dimension qui est très importante qui
est la capacité à dire on a un poids
dans la société qui se marque par la
capacité à créer de l'affrontement à
créer du désordre à poser des
difficultés à mettre à l'épreuve
l'appareil de l'État et ça c'est quelque
chose qui explique en grand partie la
nature des comportements d'affrontement
et après le fait que par-dessus se
greffe plus tardivement dans la séquence
plutôt des comportements de vol et de
prédation matérielle laence vous oui sur
le fait que beaucoup de de la violence
des émetiers ce soit dirigés vers des
bâtiments qui représentent en fait les
services publics et la démocratie plus
largement je pense que ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut y voir ce qu'il faut y lire
c'est que il ne suffit pas d'avoir des
lieux d'avoir des services qui existent
encore faut-il que le Rec cours soit
réel soit effectif on sait que dans ces
quartiers l'abstention par exemple est
absolument massive le fait que ces
jeunes s'en prennent à des mairies des
commissariats bien sûr mais aussi des
écoles des bibliothèques ça dit sans
doute quelque chose d'une forme de
frustration démocratique dans le sens où
ces jeunes certainement ne se sentent
pas concernés et suffisamment intégrés
dans la démocratie et il ne suffit pas
d'en avoir la possibilité il faut
travailler sur ce ce lien de façon plus
efficace alors on va continuer de parler
de la la présence policière et je
m'appuie toujours sur ce sondage odoxa
pour Fiducial et le et le Figaro avec
deux questions qu'on va enchaîner
première question avez-vous le sentiment
que l'insécurité a augmenté dans les
banlieux la réponse est massivement oui
87 % vous le voyez euh autre question
avez-vous vu le sentiment que la police
ou la gendarmerie sont suffisamment
présentes dans les quartiers difficiles
là le nom l'emporte à 85 %. Laurence
zarveau je reviens vers vous justement
pour revenir à l'enquête que vous aviez
réalisé avec destin commin qui était
peut-être plus contrasté on va dire plus
nuancé que que que ces résultats alors
sur la
sécurité le sentiment de sécurité je
pense que c'est extrêmement important de
d'y insister nous avions demandé est-ce
que là où vous habitez vous vous sentez
en sécurité ou deux Français sur trois
répondent oui donc c'est une très large
majorité donc le discours qui a un petit
peu proliféré à ce moment-là d'une sorte
d'insécurité généralisée ne correspond
pas à la réalité bien sûr là vous
donniez des chiffres sur les banlieux en
particulier donc on parle de choses mais
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à
une tendance générale à pousser cette
vision d'une insécurité généralisée et
grandissante qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité ensuite en ce qui concerne le
rapport à la police d'une part et au
jeunes des quartiers d'autre part
c'était vraiment le cœur de notre
interrogation après ce moment de de
peut-être de sidération nationale on est
tout de suite passé de la sidération à
la polarisation c'est-à-dire on nous a
sommé de faire un choix de se
positionner de de prendre parti de
choisir un camp entre les policiers d'un
côté les jeunes des quartiers de l'autre
c'était la cagnotte a et la cagnote B
vous vous souvenez celle pour la famille
du policier celle pour le la famille du
jeune nel il fallait choisir absolument
les Français ne se retrouvent pas dans
cette vision
maniquenne 76 % d'entre eux donc trois
Français sur qu considèrent que on peut
ressentir de la colère au sujet de la
mort de Nel et en même temps penser que
la police a une mission particulièrement
difficile et pour approfondir un petit
peu sur cette question du du rapport à
la police et du besoin de soutien de
reconnaissance il est très très
majoritaire dans les chez les Français
la vision d'une France antiflic là aussi
et ne correspond pas à la réalité ce
sont 82 % des Français qui considèrent
que les policiers se mettent en danger
pour nous et qu'il mérite notre respect
et 69 % qui considèrent que les
policiers sont trop mal payés comp tenu
de leur conditions de travail est-ce
qu'il y a pas un presque l'éléphant dans
la pièce là qui est la question du
dialogue
entre la société pres tr ma question et
la police absolument je pense que c'est
l'angle mort pour le moment des répons
votre avis là-dessus oui après je pense
que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
nuancé que ça parce que laérité ce que
vous disiez c'est la très grande
majorité des Français y compris dans les
quartiers populaires attendent les
forces de l'ordre ont besoin des forces
de l'ordre et sont les premières
victimes des forces de l'ordre quand
elles ne sont pas suffisamment là parce
qu'il y a pas suffisamment de moyens
qu'il y a pas suffisamment d'effectif et
que c'est un bétier qui est dur la très
grande majorité des jeunes des quartiers
populaires c'est pas des an les quelques
centaines ou quelques milliers de jeunes
qui sont livrés à des opérations de
pillage ce qui était un effet d'
d'opportunité un effet de foule ou à des
destruction d'équipement public ce qui
était du vandalisme pur et simple c'est
une infime minorité y compris dans des
quartiers franciliens où il y a eu des
dégradations extrêmement dures on parle
de quelques centaines de jeunes qui sont
plus des délincant des jeunes sur
quelques dizaines de milliers
d'habitants tout petite proportion mais
si on élargit la question de
je là on va sentim qui ce qui me gêne
c'est que quand on parle
de d'une réponse sécuritaire en fait on
assimile l'ensemble de la jeunesse à ces
quelques centaines de personnes et quand
on parle d'une absence de reconnaissance
ou une défiance de la police on parle
toujours de ces quelques centaines de
personnes la réalité c'est que des
milliers des millions de personnes
veulent vivre paisiblement y compris
dans ces quartiers-là quand il y a des
trafics en bas des immeubles c'est les
mamans c'est les jeunes qui sont en
dehors des trafics qui sont les premiers
à espérer que la police la police
municipale puisse intervenir et qui en
sont les victimes alors après ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'on est sur des policiers
qui font un travail extrêmement dur qui
sont beaucoup plus sous pression
aujourd'hui qu'avant sur lesquels d'une
certaine manière le
le quand vous intervenez quand vous êtes
policier maintenant vous êtes filmé
enfin vous avez le téléphone on vous
film on vous met en situation de de euh
d' d'insécurité en situation de de doute
par rapport à votre intervention il y a
assez souvent le sentiment de ne pas
forcément être soutenu politiquement et
on voit bien la difficulté qu'on
beaucoup de forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui on est quand même passé au
mois de juin à la limite d'avoir des
forces de l'ordre qui disent on se
retire à un moment quand même mesurer
les choses oui Antoine jordin oui un
point qui est important en fait je crois
c'est que la relation c'est pas entre
l'ensemble de la société et la police et
ce sont des situations particulières
notamment les conditions d'usage de la
force par la police et ce qui a provoqué
la réaction au début de ces émeut de
juin euh c'est une situation qui a été
dénoncée y compris par les pouvoirs
publics notamment par le Président de la
République comme étant un geste
inacceptable et en fait il y a un
véritable débat sur la position qu'on pu
avoir un certain nombre aussi de membres
des organisations policières qui
soutenaient la démarche et réclament le
droit de faire usage de l'arme dans de
telles conditions donc ça pose des
débats sur quels sont les éléments de
doctrine quels sont les éléments de
stratégie et on renvoie toujours à la
question de la responsabilité
individuelle des policiers sur le
terrain qui parfois font face à des
sitation très difficile mais ça renvoie
aussi à des questions de stratégie de la
part de l'état de ce qui il souhaite
être la forme d'action de la police de
ce qu'il souhait être les modalités
précises d'usage de la force par la
police et donc ça ça renvoie à des
questions légales et puis aussi à des
questions stratégiques et donc je pense
qu'il faut l'insérer dans une discussion
plus globale et un point je crois qui
est extrêmement important c'est de voir
que on parle tout le temps des auteurs
en disant on juge sur la base des
condamnations qui sont ces auteurs mais
en fait on sait pas qui sont les auteurs
on a quelques centaines de personnes qui
ont été interpellées mais s'il y a eu
des émeutes France entière avec 80000
policiers sur le terrain c'est parce
qu'il y avait des milliers voire des
dizaines de milliers d' auteur de
protestation violente sur le territoire
on voit simplement ceux qui ont été
jugés aujourd'hui dans les statistiques
et dans les chiffres officiels mais on
ne connaît pas le profil de tous ceux
qui ont participé 4000 personnes ont été
interpellé 2000 2000 ont été jugés suff
ça suffit pas pour vous pour avoir un
d'ailleurs assez précise de de de qui
était là quoi les policiers sur le
terrain vous le disent il y a plein de
personnes qui n'ont pas pu interpeller
parce qu'il y avait pas dans plein
placement pour les mettre en garde à vue
il y a des personnes qui ont été placées
en garde à vue qui ont été relâché
immédiatement parce qu'il y avait pas
matière ou que la procédure pénale
respondit pas donc il y a une question
pas seulement de ce qui est la loi mais
de ce que sont les moyens de mener les
instructions de mener les procédures
jusqu'au bout et donc c'est une question
de capacité de la réponse de l'appareil
pénal plus qu'une question de contenu
législatif des dispositifs on continue
sur ce thème et je vous propose un
extrait de des annonces de la première
ministre tout à l'heure à la à la
Sorbonne qui concerne justement la
question des des de la police et
notamment des pouvoirs de la police
municipale on l'écoute pour les maires
qui le souhaitent
je vous propose de franchir une nouvelle
étape dans le continuum de sécurité et
de donner la possibilité aux polices
municipales d'accomplir certains actes
de police
judiciaire ces pouvoirs s'exerceront
naturellement sous le contrôle des
parquets nous lancerons une concertation
avec vous et les associations d'élus
afin de bâtir un texte de loi les
ministres Gérard géraldanin et éc Dupont
Moretti y reviendront ser trsileire on
va pas débattre sur l'expression
continuum de la sécurité c'est pas notre
notre thème Laurence de nerveau votre
avis sur ce
dialogue police société et peut-être
justement les différences
générationnelles parce que c'est c'est
l'un des l'un des résultats aussi
intéressants de votre enquête
effectivement c'était un des
enseignements importants euh après le
constat selon lequel effectivement
l'opinion est majoritairement nuancée
modérée et qu'il y a une reconnaissance
très majoritaire de de la difficulté du
travail des policiers et cetera ensuite
on peut noter effectivement des
distinctions selon les générations les
plus âgés étant encore plus en soutien
de la police les plus jeunes étant dans
une prise de distance un peu plus nette
euh quelques chiffres donc l'idée que
les policiers se mettent en danger pour
nous et méritent notre respect c'est 91
% d'opinion favorable chez les plus de
65 ans contre 68 % ça reste très
majoritaire hein mais 68 % chez les 18
24 ans et de la même façon 77 % des
seniors considèrent que les policiers
sont trop mal payés cont tenu de leurs
conditions de travail et ce n'est le cas
que de 50 50 % des plus jeunes
jean-filipe dugouin Clément les sur les
policiers municipaux est-ce que est-ce
queun part de la solution peut venir de
des polices municipales du de de de
pouvoir de pouvoir des policiers
municipaux accru oui bien sûr bah la
réalité c'est que il y a 20 ans de cela
très peu de communes avaient des polices
municipales ça vit être des grosses
communes généralement de droite et
aujourd'hui bon l'immense majorité des
communes de plus de 10000 habitants et
même en dessous sur des 5 6 7000
habitants sont dotés de police
municipale le plus souvent armé ou pas
de de plus en plus de plus en plus y
compris parce que c'est une demande de
la part des policiers eux-mêmes pour
pouvoir se protéger et les communes qui
n'armment pas ont énormément de
difficultés de recrutement et de
stabilisation de leurs effectifs parce
que les effec les effectifs tournent ça
fait partie des revendications bien
normales des policiers municipaux la
réalité c'est que pourquoi est-ce que
les communes ont investis dans des
polices municipales dans des caméras
dans des dispositifs de ce type parce
que l'État s'est désengagé parce que
depuis 30 ans l'État c'est désengagé
massivement et quand la Première
ministre dans un langage technocratique
remarquable que vous avez souligné le
continuum de sécurité c'est vrai que je
pense que ça parle beaucoup au français
renvoie vers les polices municipales la
réalité c'est qu'on ne sait pas vers
quoi on renvoie on renvoie une loi ça
fait 4 mois qu'il y a eu des émeutes au
bout de 4 mois on nous dit ah benah on
va faire un symposium pour réfléchir
avec les associations d'élus sur la
façon dont on peut faire évoluer la loi
ce qui sera compliqué parce qu'on a des
problèmes constitutionnels mais
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que c'est
les communes qui inv dans les moyens
parce que quand ça se passe mal dans une
commune c'est le maire qui se fait
engueuler euh le le ministre le préfet
ils n'ont pas ce contact direct là et
aujourd'hui un policier municipal pour
beaucoup de choses ne peut pas
intervenir s'il n'est pas accompagné de
policiers nationaux ou de gendarmes et
donc on a besoin là-dessus sur des actes
de verbalisation d'alcotest sur un
certain nombre de points de pouvoir
progresserz dans les choses absolument
foles euh C éé un vrai problème pendant
les émeutes un policier municipal ne
peut pas rentrer chez lui avec son arme
de service
un policier national peut le faire la
seule chose c'est que un policier
municipal qui rentre à 3h du matin il
est autant potentiellement victime d'une
agression qu'à policier national ce qui
a été le cas pendant ces périodeslà et
quand les armes sont au poste si le
poste est brûlé bah vous n'avez plus
d'armes vous n'avez plus de police
municipale pendant 3 semaines un mois le
temps de récupérer des des des
autorisations est-ce que un mot
là-dessus encore Antoine jardin sur
j'allais parler le le Gérald d'Anin il
faut il faut mettre du bleu dans dans
dans nos villes ou dans nos quartiers
difficiles euh mais mais quel bleu pour
faire quoi alors c'est toute la question
parce qu'en fait la police qui est
présente le plus souvent dans les
quartiers marginalisés c'est une police
d'intervention c'est pas une police du
quotidien c'est une police qui vient
quand il y a des problèmes et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on voit nous chercheurs on
est sollicité quand il y a des émeutes
quand il y a pas d'émeutes c'est pas un
sujet la sécurité des banlieux c'est un
sujet quand il y a un événement
d'ampleur nationale qui intéresse et
cetera et donc on voit bien qu'il y a
sans doute un déficit de connaissance de
la relation de long terme sur ces
territoire et des effectifs qui sont
souvent très faibles sur les quartiers
les plus
marginalisés et on a vu aussi que
c'était une difficulté pour des
territoires plus ruraux ou plus éloignés
des grands pôles urbains où en fait il y
a pas la capacité à apporter rapidement
des forces d'intervention et c'est ça la
logique de vouloir essayer de faciliter
les accès quand il y a des difficultés
alors c'est quoi c'est c'est le le bon
vieux retour à la police de proximité
c'est c'est c'est l'une des solution
c'est une solution en fait qui est en
oscillation permanente on essaie d'en
faire d'en défaire d'en refaire et c'est
le cas dans la plupart des pays du monde
et en fait on voit bien quand on veut
finalement que la police municipale
fasse la même chose que la police
nationale c'est qu'on dit simplement il
y a pas assez de policiers nationaux et
on est dans une logique de compensation
de palliation à une situation qui est
pas satisfaisante du point de vue de la
sécurité mais est- est-ce qu'il risque
d'y avoir une grande déception par
rapport à ce que propose Elisabeth
bornne parce que on sait que d'un point
de vue juridique c'est extrêmement
compliqué ça a déjà été retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel en 2021 donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir leur faire
faire réellement en plus ça au policiers
municipaux ça va être une toute petite
loi certainement alors il est
vraisemblable que la plupart des
dispositions qui sont annoncé en tout
cas certaines DESP annoncées sont
difficiles à faire progresser au plan
constitutionnel parce qu'elles sont
finalement en rupture avec un certain
nombre de principes qui ont été
enterinés je pense notamment à la
responsabilité parentale qui est quelque
chose de difficile à envisagerors
responsabilité parentale on va en parler
avec Tam mais d'abord je propose à
Mathias AR de nous rejoindre bonsoir
Mathias pour parler de des émeties on
l'a déjà évoqué ensemble Antoine jardin
le profil type des émetiers il y a des
éléments nouveaux qui permettent de de
donner un peu plus de détails oui il y
avait hier au Sénat Thomas une audition
de trois inspecteurs généraux qui ont
rendu un rapport sur les émeutes survenu
un peu partout cet été sur le territoire
et ce qui ressort de ce rapport et bien
c'est que l'hémetier type est un homme
de nationalité française qu'il est âgé
de 23 ans célibataire sans enfants
hébergé par ses parents qu'il détient un
diplôme de type bac et qu'il est en
activité ce profil et ben il est établi
sur les personnes majeures
définitivement condamné au 31 juillet
soit un échantillonnage d'environ 395
individus par ailleurs et c'est à noter
Thomas en tout cas à ne pas négliger 28
% des hmetiers sont mineurs et parmi
lesquels 36 % d'entre eux sont issus de
l'île-de-fance alors ce rapport il
établit également un profil judiciaire
oui car si la totalité des infractions
concerne des vols aggravés ou des
dégradations de biens privés il est
intéressant de savoir si ces hémetiers
étaient des professionnels entre
guillemets donc des récidivistes ou
plutôt des primos condamnés de
l'échantillonnage analysé il en ressort
un profil un profil
contrasté un profil judiciaire que nous
avons qualifié de plus contrasté puisque
57 % de ces auteurs condamnés définitif
au 31 au 31 juillet 57 % sont sans
antécédents judiciaaires évidemment 43
ont des antécédents
Judici donc voilà le la sign pourquoi
nous avons choisi ce qualificatif de
contraster ouis l'inspectrice générale
de la justice précise que au regard du
jeune âge moyen des condamnés la grande
majorité
des condamnations pour les récidivistes
avait eu lieu dans les 12 à 18 mois
précédents les émeutes et puis on l'a
déjà évoqué dans dans dans ce débat les
motivation des émeutiers oui les émeutes
avaient débuté suite à la mort de Naël
et pourtant l'émotion liée au décès du
jeune de 17 ans est invoqué que dans
moins de 8 % des cas lorsqu'on interroge
les mises en cause sur leur motivation
le rapport montre que la plupart des
condamnés n'expriment ni revendication
idéologique ni véritable volonté
politique affirmée ce qui ressort en
revanche des échanges avec les hmeutiers
notamment les plus jeunes c'est
l'opportunisme et l'influence du groupe
pour preuve justement cet échange Thomas
présent dans le dans le rapport
honnêtement je ne sais pas j'ai suivi le
mouvement de foule je sortais pour faire
du foot mais si j'était parti mes potes
auraient dit que je suis une un
mec qui esquive enfin et c'est aussi à
noter de nombreux auteurs invoquent même
la curiosité ou le besoin d'adrénaline
merci beaucoup Mathias on va reparler de
du profil et des motivations mais mais
peut-être un mot pour pour commencer
jean-filippe Duguin Clément sur la
réponse pénale euh je je le donnais là
près de 2000 personnes condamnées 1787 à
des peines d'emprisonnement voilà elle a
été suffisamment ferme par ce qu'on dit
souvent la la justice l'accise dans ce
pays et cetera et cetera non je crois
qu'il y a eu une une véritable réponse
pénale que pour le coup le gouvernement
a donné des instructions extrêmement
fermes alors ceux qui sont fait attraper
c'est un pourcentage c'est pas tous ce
que vous disiez effectivement le
piochage ou le P King il est pas
forcément totalement représentatif moi
sur ce que j'ai pu voir ou pour discuter
avec des collègues maires franciliens
c'était quand même beaucoup plus jeunes
que des moyennes de 23 ans c'est c'était
jusqu'à du 13 14 ans beaucoup des
mineurs ou des très jeunes majeurs mais
une moyenne d'âge de 23 ans al peut-être
que ceux qui se sont fait attraper qui
avait déjà un casier du coup sur lesquel
des procédures ont été poursuivies
plutôt qu'un simple rappel à loi enfin
je sais pas exactement comment on a
comptabilisé le le profil de 23 ans
juste parce que parom Mathias l'a dit
mais pour être bien précis il est établi
sur les personnes majeuresam
définitivement condamné au prier au 31
juillet ça explique ça explique ce
décalage entre votre perception réité en
perception mais je voyais que le taux de
mineur était plus important en
Île-deFrance donc je peux avoir un
prisme un peu fausé dessus mais c'est
quand même des des très très jeunes
mineurs beaucoup plus d'ailleurs qu'en
2004 on voit qu'on est descendu 2004
c'était beaucoup des 161 là on est
quasiment sur la tranche d'âge
précédente la réponse pénale elle a été
faite elle a été faite de manière forte
alors on peut toujours trouver que au
cas particulier telle situation ça être
un peu plus un peu moins la réalité
c'est que les procédures globalement ont
suivi mais quand on a dit ça c'est
comment on fait en sorte que dans 1 an 2
ans 3 ans pour une question totalement
utilisée parce que l'espèce c'est pas la
mort de Naël à nter qui fait que il y a
des à Strasbourg à Marseille à
Nantes à montargy des équipements
publics qui soient brûlés qui a des
policier qui soit pris à parti c'est un
effet de meute c'est un effet d'obè
c'est une forme de désérance une forme
d'économie les réseaux sociaux qui
prennent une part absolument terrible y
compris dans l'organisation matérielle
des émeutes et ça c'est un véritable
sujet la première ministre a beaucoup
parlé des réseaux sociaux sur les
réseaux de drogue mais par rapport à la
gestion des émeutes et à la mobilité des
émeutiers ça a été un problème majeur
majeur auquel on a été confronté mais
comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte de ne
pas se retrouver dans la même situation
dans 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans où le premier
prétexte donnera l'occasion d'aller tout
casser et bien si on veut pas avoir ça
il faut remettre en place un plan où on
puisse avoir autre chose que ne rien
faire dans des quartiers que de pas
avoir de de d'espérance que de pas avoir
de projection de soi-même ouais Antoine
jardin ça pose la question je vous donne
la parole juste après ça pose la
question de même si on parle là de de de
ceux essentiellement jeallis dire celles
et ceux mais c'est quand même surtout
des garçons qui ont été emprisonnés
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux quand ils
vont sortir de prison une grande
question hein 300 personnes condamnées
quelle suivi de long terme parce qu'on
parle de personnes relativement jeunes
qui sont condamnées à la prison ferme
pour une moitié d'entre s antécédent
quel est le suivi de long terme quand
ils sortent et qu'il reviennent dans
leur quartier à l'été prochain c'est un
sujet qui mérite d'être discuté et qui
doit s'inscrire dans une stratégie de
plus long terme et puis en fait ces
chiffres sont des chiffres sur la base
des condamnés et on ne connaît pas le
profil des hmetiers on fait comme si on
le connaissait et je suis très surpris
de voir que on reprend ces chiffres
issus des condamnés pour généraliser aux
émetiers et on a plein de témoignages
qui mon que ça ne correspond pas le
maire de montarg nous explique qu'il y a
eu dans sa commune une seule personne
condamnée pour l'ensemble des faits qui
ont eu Liu dans la commune parce qu'il y
avait pas de force de l'ordre pour
s'interposer ça on pourra on pourra
l'analyser quand il y a il y a un
travail sociologique à faire déjà en
cours il y a des travaux en cours et
puis il y a des choses qu'on ne pourra
jamais véritablement complètement savoir
parce que personne n'est la liste des
personnes qui ont participé aux émeutes
donc il faut aussi avoir mon avis un peu
de recul et se dire en fait on a des
indications mais on n pas des chiffres
robustes qui nous permettent de dire à
coup sûr tel facteur tel âge tel
territoire joue un rôle déterminant donc
ça je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment très important à pointer
Laurence zerve vouliez intervenir sur ce
thèmelà oui alors d'abord rappeler du
point de vue de l'opinion générale des
Français sur ces jeunes comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure on parle d'une
toute petite minorité par rapport aux
jeunes des quartiers et ça les Français
font cette distinction aussi ils sont
majoritairement par exemple inquiets du
climat d'hostilité à l'égard des jeunes
de quartier et de cette généralisation
qui qui qui a suivi cet épisode mais je
voulais revenir également sur la
question des réseaux sociaux qui
évidemment ne sont pas la cause euh de
cette crise de ces émeutes mais qui en
sont très clairement un facteur
aggravant là-dessus quelques chiffres
sont éclairants les Français dans leur
ensemble sont très conscients des
risques et demandent plus de contrôle ce
sont 45 % des Français qui considèrent
que les réseaux sociaux sont un danger
pour la démocratie 80 % qui considèrent
que ce soit un lieu c'est un lieu
dangereux pour nos enfants et ce sont
même 2 tiers des Français qui sont
favorables à l'interdiction des réseaux
sociaux pour les jeunes de moins de 16
ans alors cette adhésion progresse avec
l'âge à mesure qu'on progresse son âge
mais ce sont tout de même 45 % des
jeunes des 18-25 ans qui sont favorables
à cette interdiction des réseaux sociaux
au moins de 16 ans ce qui est quand même
assez frappant on va parler de la
responsabilité parentale et et je vous
propose pour ouvrir cette ce dernier
chapitre de notre débat d'écouter le
ministre de l'intérieur on est très tôt
après les les émeut il parle notamment
du profil des des émetiers de leur
jeunesse et puis ensuite il il évoque
cette question de la responsab habité
parentale dire que la moyenne des gens
encore une fois que nous avons
interpellé c'est une moyenne d'âge de 17
ans avec parfois des des enfants il y a
pas d'autrre mot de 12 13 ans qui
étaient des pyromanes ou qui ont attaqué
des des des forces de l'ordre ou qui ont
attaqué des des élus et et je pense que
il faut qu'on se pose tous cette
question la responsabilité des des
familles des parents parce que c'est pas
la police nationale ou à la gendarmerie
ou même au maire ou même à l'état de de
régler le le problème quand un enfant de
12 ans met le feu à une école je pense
que c'est
une question qui relève de l'autorité
parentale alors c'est une partie de la
réponse des réponses annoncées par la
première ministre cet après-midi Thame
des travaux d'intérêt général pour les
parents défaillants c'est une mesure qui
va certainement faire beaucoup débat et
une mesure sur laquelle on se pose déjà
beaucoup de questions déjà un qu'est-ce
qu'être un parent défaillant est-ce
qu'on est défaillant dès lors que son
enfant a commis des actes de délinquence
est-ce que on est défaillant parce qu'on
a soi-même vraiment abandonné son enfant
est-ce qu'on peut être considéré comme
déf an parce qu'on est l'unique référent
dans une famille monoparentale comp par
à 5h du matin bref qu'on est défaillant
parce qu'on est dépassé alors qu'on a vu
que les famille monoparentale était sur
reprprésenté hein dans les profils
l'autre question c'est un parent peut-il
être responsable des infractions
commises par son enfant juridiquement
c'est clair la réponse c'est non on est
pénalement responsable que de son propre
fait en revanche un parent est tenu
d'assurer l'éducation de son enfant et
il y a déjà bien un article qui existe
au code pénal c'est l'article
227-17 qui sanctionne les parents qui en
raison d'une éducation défaillante ont
laissé leur enfants entrer dans la
délinquence he c'est puni déjà de 2 ans
de prison c'est puni de 30000 € d'amende
dans les fait ce n'est jamais appliqué
alors est-ce que des travaux d'intérêt
général seraient plus appliqué bon il va
falloir voir avec les magistrats sans
prendre au aux parents des enfants
délinquants c'est vraiment pas une
nouveauté non c'est notamment une des
vieilles lunes de la droite les stages
de de parentalité dont parle Élisabeth
bbor déjà présent dans une loi de 2007
la suppression des allocations
familiales en cas d'absentéisme scolaire
déjà appliqué sous Nicolas Sarkozi après
une loi qui a été adoptée en 2010 puis
abrogé sous François Hollande en 2013
qui était l'auteur de ce texte était
déjà Éric cioti alors simple député qui
depuis en tant que président des
républicains propose donc la même chose
le même dispositif pour les parents de
jeunes hémetiers c'est donc dans les
vieux pots qu'on fait les meilleures
soupes une recette qui semble avoir
convaincu le le président de la
République qui a déclaré en visitant un
commissariat début juillet il faudrait
qu'à la première infraction on arrive à
sanctionner financièrement et facilement
les familles une sorte de tarif minimum
dès la première connerie ces dispositifs
ont-ils fait leur preuve B ce vieux PAA
n'a pas fait l'objet de beaucoup
d'évaluation malheureusement mais en
tout cas la suppression des allocations
familiales en 3 ans a touché 462
familles et l'absentisme scolaire a
plutôt augmenté sur la période sans
qu'on puisse non plus un cela non plus à
la proposition de loi d'éic cioti et le
pompon qui est raconté à l'époque par
l'ancien président du tribunal pour
enfants de bobini Jean-Pierre rosensveg
c'est que ce sont les départements qui
ont été les premiers touchés au
portefeuille puisque leur été confiés
des enfants en rupture scolaire voilà ce
qu'on cherche donc à travers ces mesures
annoncées par Elisabeth born ce sont
sans doute moins des dispositifs
efficaces que des signaux politique de
fermeté bref c'est de la communication
pour dire à l'opinion que le
gouvernement gère les affaires pour
terminer un petit rappel historique pe
remonter beaucoup plus loin c'est ça
exactement cibler les parents dans les
discours politiques sur la délinquence
juvénile et bien ça remonte au 19e
siècle c'est ce qu'a montré l'historien
Jean-Jacques yvorel c'est au moment de
l'industrialisation on considère que le
prolétariat urbain c'est la classe
dangereuse et que si des enfants de ces
classes populaires sont déviants c'est
parce que leurs parents exercent alors
une influence néfaste alors que au
contraire on va médicaliser
psychologiser les problèmes des enfant
déviant des classes aisées c'est un peu
ce qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui he le vous
n'élevez pas bien vos enfants s'adresse
surtout aux parents de classe populaire
or riches ou pauvre les parents ne sont
pas responsables de rien ça ne signifie
pas pour autant qu'ils sont responsables
de tout merci tameler est-ce que c'est
encore un marqueur politique ça la
question de la responsabilité parentale
moi ce qui me frappe dans ce sur ce
sujet et je trouve que les éléments qui
viennent d'être apportés est extrêmement
éclairant et précis c'est que il y a
quand même un petit angle mort qui est
de qui parle-t-on quand on parle de
parents Vous avez très justement
souligné que les familles monoparentales
étaient surreésenté parmi les parents
des ametiers peut-on dire que parmi les
familles monoparentales il y a pas loin
de 90 % de femmes seules de mamans solo
voilà donc peut-on parler de façon plus
précise en l'occurrence des pères et et
s'agissant de nantère ces chiffres sont
tout à fait frappants sur les familles
monoparentales en l'occurrence maman
solo et est-ce que on peut aussi parler
sur ce sujet du non règlement des
pensions alimentaire de ce genre
de voilà je pense que c'est c'est quand
même un peu l'éléphant dans pièce là
aussi pour reprendre votre expression
effectivement on peut dire ça dans les
mesures annoncées par ellisabeth born on
est en plein dans ce que vous vous
détaillez à l'instant et il y a
effectivement nous allons créer une
contribution financière citoyenne et
familiale que les mineurs et leurs
parents de vont payer à des associations
de victimes et elle veut en outre
s'assurer que lorsqu'un mineur a causé
des dégradations les deux parents qu'ils
soient séparés ou non qu'ils vivent avec
leur enfant ou non non soit responsable
financièrement des dommages causés
est-ce que c'est réaliste jean-philppe
dugouin Clément tout simplement est-ce
qu'on comment mettre en place de telles
mesures je pense que enfin vous avez
tout dit on est 4 mois après en 4 mois
on a rien fait donc on fait une
opération de communication pour oui mais
ça on peut dire que 4 mois c'était le
temps nécessaire de la réflexion
pour avec des choses à peu près précises
à peu près solides et qu'on peut mettre
en place là la plupart des choses on est
sur des choses qui existent déjà qui
sont difficiles à mettre en place ou
qu'on renvoie une loi ou une discussion
ultérieure on peut quand même se
demander ce qui a été fait on voit bien
qu'on est dans la gestion d'un effet
communicationnel moi ce qui me gêne
énormément là-dedans c'est je suis pas
tellement convaincu qu'on puisse mettre
les choses en place expliquer à des
parents qui sont séparés dont les deux
dont habitent à 600 km l'un de l'autre
qui a une corresponsabilité pénale
pénale des enfants je vois pas comment
on le met en œuvre très concrètement ou
en tout cas je vois pas comment on va au
bout bon moi si je prends l'exemple sur
ma commune dans les arrestations qu'il y
a eu il y a eu un jeune alors qui
n'était pas de ma commune mais dont le
père travaille dans les forces de
l'ordre donc est-ce que cette personne
devrait faire des tiches parce que son
fils est un délinquant je ça arrive
aussi dans des familles très bien donc
moi je veux bien tout ce qu'on veut mais
ça ça me semble assez compliqué la
responsabilité pécunière et financière
il faut le faire il faut le faire il
faut le systématiser on a probablement
pas suffisamment utilisé les dispositifs
qui existaient pour pouvoir le faire et
puis surtout ce qui moi me semble
important c'est de sortir des enfants
quand effectivement on a dans une
famille pour de bonnes ou de mauvaise
raison mais un enfant de 12 ans alors
qu'on est dans des périodes d'émeutes de
13 ans qui est tout seul le soir dehors
à 23h à minuit ça veut dire soit que la
famille ne s'en occupe pas soit qu'elle
n'y arrive pas parce qu'elle est
dépassée et donc dans ce cas-là ben il
faut il faut avoir le courage de dire on
sort l'enfant du domicile familial on le
sort du quartier on le met dans une
structure adaptée ce qui a été évoqué
par la première ministre maintenant
quand on a dit ça moi je crois pas au
centre éducatif fermé géré par l'armée
je pense que l'armée a autre chose à
faire que de gérer des centres éducatifs
fermés mais je pense P qu'il faut
augmenter ses centres éducatifs combien
on en fait quand avec quel
moyen à la parentalité allez à vous le
dernier mot pardon Antoine jardin
effectivement sur le le le le recours à
des militaires pour encadrer ces jeunes
délinquants ça nous ça nous rappelle qui
c'est royale si je me trompe c'est une
idée classique effectivement qui a
priori n'est pas tellement soutenue par
les militaires qui effectivement
considèrent qu'ils ont d'autres missions
ils sont souvent appelés pour des
affaires de maintien de l'ordre public
qui n'est pas dans leur dans leur
composante je crois que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'en fait on a une
société qui de plus en plus utilise la
violence dans les contestations
politiques on a vu les gilets jaunes on
a vu les mouvements écologistes avec
saintsine par exemple aujourd'hui on
voit les émeutes de banlieu et donc ce
qui se passe c'est qu'en fait on a une
dérégulation des mouvements de
protestation qui déboug vers davantage
de violence et on sait plus par quel
bout les prendre et par quels moyen les
canaliser et en fait il faut à mon avis
sortir du cas spécifique des banlieux
pour avoir une réflexion plus globale
comment est-ce que politiquement on
construit ces rapports sociaux là pour
éviter qu'il bascule dans la violence
merci beaucoup merci à tous notre débat
était forcément centré sur l'aspect sc
ire parce que c'était l'actualité du
jour mais il y a beaucoup de choses à
dire aussi sur l'urbanisme la façon de
de de penser ces ces espaces et
d'ailleurs je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Jean-Philippe dugouin Clément
l'habitat fait le citoyen publié aux
éditions de l'eau merci encore à à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat à bientôt
sur sur public C